the jurgen experience well that's what i
wanted to talk to you about one of the
things like
did anything shift once people started
buying guns
when there was this this this moment
where
what was the the number of gun sales
went up something crazy like 40
something percent higher than that
really yeah okay let's let's
find it let's guess i'm thinking it's
like 40 jeremy what do you think what's
your guess
what's the percentage yeah that sounds
right i just bet i have a different
question but
okay good i'm looking that up because i
see the statistic
of 500 000 to 3 million but it's why
would the center for disease control be
really because because they they want to
make it a health care issue
because if so that you hear them say it
all the time they say this is a public
health issue
it's easier to sell gun control when you
deem it a publix no different than what
think getting coveted in the vaccine why
wouldn't it be the atf though
because it's easier to sell it as a
public health issue i know but firearms
is literally in their title
yeah exactly and if you say the way
biden says it you switch tobacco
but but you gotta yeah they're very good
the one thing i will say about them and
when i say them i mean the gun control
lobby
which generally speaking and i get a lot
of people who follow me who are more
liberal
they hate when i bring up the the
democrats they hate it
because they think i'm just trying to
push this one-sided
narrative with respect to the
republicans no
it is what it is if you look at all the
gun control legislation you look at
anybody who's pushing gun control
the vast majority of them i'm talking 99
of the time they are democrats why do
you think that is
because democrats are the democratic
ideology
is based around bigger government right
and so you can't necessarily exact your
control over a group of people
if they have something as self-reliant
as a firearm do you really think that's
what it is i do think that would agree
that is it
i think it's that the ideology behind
being a left-wing person
is you want less violence and i think
maybe you're more reluctant to actually
take into account
real human nature and real the real
potential breakdown of society that
would cause you to need a gun
i think they're more idealistic more
utopian and
perhaps more delusional i think the
people who vote democrat
believe that i think the people in power
have a different agenda
i think i think from their and honestly
they are they are the proverbial hammer
so when you when you're at when you when
your fundamental ideologies are based
around bigger government
you think the solution for everything is
more government right
so if if if a shooting happens
right and come on do we really think
government is the most efficient entity
at
solving problems in our country no
people complain about the government
all the time but when you are the
government
and you get something like a shooting
and people like we need to do something
about it
okay more government let's throw these
laws out here like restrict that take
that so
they take on a more per apparent role as
opposed to
an entity designed to find true
solutions to fix a problem
so they say okay well if this small
number of people are killing people with
guns take the guns away
it's just oversimplified approach to uh
to any problem that comes up because
they're not really about
getting to the true issue of the problem
they just want to either look like
they're doing something about
it and so they'll just take the easiest
approach
or they'll try to scapegoat it on
something because at the end of the day
they realize that their ineptitude with
respect to leadership
is going to be put on full blast more
specifically our inner cities
right right so if the vast majority i
mean close to 80 percent of gun
homicides in this country are coming
from our
inner cities and we have 400 million
guns in this country is it really 80
damn near yes it's high it's high
i'm talking gun homicides right not not
like gun deaths
right um because and it's driven by gang
and drug violence that's when with gun
deaths then you start including suicide
exactly
yeah and so if you understand that that
means that we're having a high
concentration of high concentrated level
of violence in very specific areas in
this country
right and as a result of that you look
at that and you say okay well
we have high concentrated we have an era
of concentrated violence in specific
areas but yet we have guns all across
the country
that don't have this violence so clearly
there's something else going on here
other than the fact that there are guns
and then
predominantly these inner cities
are led by democrats it just is what it
is it's not
possible exactly crazier so it's so it's
it stands to reason you're not doing
something in these places that you
should be doing in order
to deal with this violence yeah and then
you know in in my research and in my
study when i
i was reading this book it's called i
think i think it's like uh don't shoot
or something like that i can't remember
exact title of it
so i was reading this book and it was
talking about this program called
ceasefire
um i'm there is a program currently now
that's called ceasefire but i don't
think it's the same program
um or it's a former shell of itself but
you know this guy
this criminologist he set out and i
think it was done in boston
and they were dealing with a lot of
violence in their inner cities
and so what they did is they put
together a program was a very holistic
approach to the violence and essentially
cops came together along with the
community leaders and so forth and so on
and they they knew who
the perpetrators were of this violence
you got to think about it do we really
honestly believe that
the vast majority of these kids in the
inner city are killers
no it takes very specific type of person
to be a killer
so a lot of the killings that are taking
place in these places are done by a very
hyper-focused group of kids in these
areas
and the vast majority of the time the
police know who these kids are
police know who the perpetrators of this
violence are and so what they did is
they came together they said all right
here's what we're going to do
and they they brought they brought the
leaders of the gangs and the kids
the kids who were out on the street so
forth and so on came together and i look
we're not going to say we're not going
to rescue for the drug dealing
because i mean whatever happens happens
with respect to that but if the
if the bodies continue we're gonna make
life incredibly hard for you on these
streets
really hard and as time went on
the violence stopped the number went
down
because at the end of the day you got to
think about a lot of these kids are
carrying guns not because they want to
go and kill someone they're carrying
guns because they're scared
they grow they've grown up in an
environment that has forced them
to engage in the lifestyle that they're
in generally speaking so
if i'm a kid and even if i don't want to
partake in this in this particular
lifestyle
if that's the only thing that surrounds
me and i know that any given point
my life could be threatened i'm going to
carry a gun too or even if i'm a kid
that's like look i just want to i want
to make some extra money
i'm not i'm not justifying drug dealer
i'm not justifying the selling of drugs
but if i'm a kid who just says you know
what i want to make i want to sell money
because i grew up the only the only form
of success that i've seen were the drug
dealers in my area so i'm going to sell
drugs
of course she's going to carry a fire
i'm selling drugs there are going to be
other people who are going to try to
take his product
so forth and so on doesn't necessarily
mean he's a killer
right so when you focus entirely on the
firearm
and only on the firearm it doesn't do
anything to actually deal with the issue
that's good the underlying issue that's
happening in these places
it's a socio-economic issue when you
grow up in
poverty i'm sorry there's going to be a
predisposition with respect to your area
you're going to have more violence there
because what is the natural economy
there
drugs that's one of the weirder aspects
of gun violence is the reluctance to
address
the violence and inner cities while
focusing on the violence of the rare
mass shooter
because the inner city like if you look
at the south side of chicago it's a
regular basis yeah
it's almost every weekend there's a
bunch of homicides
i i think the reason why is because like
you you actually
touched on it how do you avoid inner
city violence
you're gonna have to fix the crime no i
mean just you how do you avoid being
stay out of the inner city exactly
however when people feel like some
random yo-yo can walk into a store
and just start shooting people it
terrifies them which is understandable
yeah
it's totally understandable but none of
these laws that they're proposing
do anything to stop this they won't
no so it begs the question is the goal
really
to try to save lives or are they
leveraging these shootings
to get this specific agenda that they
have passed
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience